[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'écris tué onze ans j'avais plein de
choses à raconter je ne savais pas trop
à qui alors j'écrivais ça dans des cas
hier pendant toute mon adolescence j'ai
rempli des cahiers en cachette et
j'écoutais du rap
j'adorais cette musique je pensais
vraiment qu'on allait changer le monde
avec cette musique
et puis mon frère raté super bien alors
un jour j'ai voulu entrer dans son
groupe
alors je viens demander et il me répond
très sérieusement prépare un couple ait
choisi une instru rendez vous à 14
heures dans la chambre casting
donc je me prépare je répète jarrige
juive sors mon couplet et à la fin il me
dit non alors moi j'étais un petit peu
vexé et donc je lui ai dit je m'en fout
de toute façon je vais faire un groupe
de rap avec mes copines et puis on va te
lâcher et puis c'est ce qu'on a fait
cette scène s'est passée j'avais 15 ans
ces termes mon retour de mon pays
d'origine
je venais d'affronter mon mariage
j'avais pas envie j'avais accepté lui
était resté là bas moi de retour ici et
puis j'étais un petit peu énervé j'en
voulais à mes parents même si je
reprenais qu'il avait fait que
reproduire ce qu'ils avaient vécu
et puis j'en voulais aussi à toutes les
filles qui avait accepté avant moi c'est
à ce moment-là que j'ai passés de
l'écriture à la scène j'avais trouvé mon
exutoire mais ça réglait pas mon
problème
et puis un jour ma soeur fait découvrir
une artiste qui s'appelle bave qui est
là ce soir
et cet album vivre ou mourir à
excédé par le vide le néant
le trou noir s'ouvre devant moi géant
quand même milliards rap en 20 piges
las de mauvaise vibes hockey lch doit
obéir que doivent choisir vivre ou
mourir mourir
[Musique]
mon dieu mon dieu je vois ma vie comme
une zone
et puis cet album je l'écouté en boucle
pendant des semaines des mois
chaque mot chaque phrase chaque
thématique abordée dans cet album
résonnait en moi
sept artistes que je ne connaissais pas
était devenu la personne la plus proche
de moi celle qui vous comprenez le mieux
et sachant son nom m'a fait dire non à
tout ce que je ne voulais pas et à tout
ce que je ne voulais plus alors je suis
parti de chez mes parents je me suis
installé sur paris et j'ai trouvé un
petit job dans l'animation
et puis un jour avec cette soeur qui est
là aussi on était dans le métro est une
femme aux cheveux verts se dirige vers
le haut avec un flyer dans la main
bonjour je m'appelle bams je fais un
concert ce soir je suis convaincu que ça
va vous plaire alors je vous laisse
imaginer deux mondes ce que j'ai pu
ressentir gelé prise dans mes bras à lui
dit à quel point elle avait été
importante dans ma vie
et puis aujourd'hui encore on travaille
avec le même producteur
alors j'ai continué à faire de la
musique en me disant que je voulais être
la base de quelqu'un et puis j'étais
resté convaincu que l'art permettait de
changer le monde
la définition qu'en fait guen s'y mêlent
c'est une artiste peintre franco
américaine le convient parfaitement
elle dit que l'art provoque toujours un
changement petit ou grand personnel ou
universel et donc il ya dix ans je crée
le groupe dit elle elle mélange de
dialogue et dilemmes et ont créé le
spectacle le mot pour mot avec l'idée de
sensibiliser
aux violences faites aux femmes est de
s'adresser à la jeunesse et donc on
parcourt les collèges et les lycées
avec ce spectacle et puis on échange
avec le public pendant une heure et
demie et puis sur un second temps des
ateliers d'écriture alors quand on fait
des ateliers d'écriture avec cette
volonté de partager d'impact et l'autre
espace des choses assez ordinaire
[Musique]
on est là on se fait face on se voit on
se regarde on se parle on s'écoute on se
livre sans retenue
on s'offre tout mise à nu on peut se
lire on peut se sentir
on peut se dire on peut se contredire
des sujets défilent les langues ses fils
plus personne ne se défile en relève le
défi au fil des mots on tire le fil au
fil des mots on tire le fil au fil des
mots on tire le fil
arrivent les pourquoi les quale qui elle
et pour qui les voilà ce qui m'arrive
les dis moi comment faire
au fil des mots on tire le fil au fil
des mots on tire le fil arrivent les
j'ai peur les géants que les gens
parlent trop les prendre sa phase
contrôler ce n'est pas drôle quand
est-ce qu'on change de rôle
au fil des mots
on tire le fil au fil des mots arrivent
les tu sais c'est la première fois que
l'on parle les avons mais pourquoi c'est
la première fois qu'on m'en parle
au fil des baux
on tire le fil au fil des mots on tire
le fil on est là on s'est fait face tout
à coup tout les craintes et face on a
osé ce causé entre camarades de classe
on sait proposer des choses pour que ça
change et ça c'est classe
[Musique]
et donc
ça marchait vraiment le slam et est
devenue un prétexte pour parler échanger
discuter et puis pour témoigner je me
suis retrouvé très rapidement avec des
témoignages de jeunes filles que de
garçons qui parlait des violences pour
la première fois l'art leur avait permis
de mettre des mots sur toutes ces choses
qu'il n'avait jamais dit avant et moi là
m'avait permis de réaliser l'ampleur des
violences en france les viols ou
tentatives de viol c'est toutes les sept
minutes
quand j'aurai fini de parler ça fera
deux de trop et donc quand on est face à
cette réalité on ne peut pas faire comme
si on ne savait pas alors en 2015 j'ai
créé l'association résonances pour
sensibiliser un maximum de jeunes sur
ces questions et puis pour donner des
moyens d'agir à toutes les personnes qui
en avaient besoin il ya toutes les
personnes qui qui voulait accompagner
ces leurs proches et qui ne savait pas
trop comment est donc sans m'en rendre
compte je crée donc l'application appel
qui permet d'alerter ses proches les
secours et puis de d'accéder à toutes
les infos qui permettent à ces victimes
de se sentir moins seuls et donc je crée
cette appli mois la slameuse avec pour
bac elle alors que je maîtrise pas x est
allé voir et je me retrouve dans deux
mois la présenter aux crs de las vegas
alors que mon anglais est pourri mais
j'y vais
est ce que je veux vous dire c'est que
pour faire reculer les violences tout le
monde doit s'y mettre
alors même si on ne sait pas trop
comment je pense que l'idée se dire
qu'il faut oser porter cette casquette
sans se demander si elle est trop grande
trop petit trop flashy
l'idée c'est de trouver comment la
porter avec son propre style
et puis sur un malentendu on peut
peut-être lancé une mode corps et donc
on réfléchit ça ensemble à nos futurs
d'espacé à égalité on contribue déjà en
faire une réalité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]